c'est l'événement cinématographique
inattendu pour le moins de sept semaines
le film l' esquive le thème une cité de
banlieue dite difficile où les jeunes
ont étudié les jeux de l'amour et du
hasard de marivaux pour un spectacle de
fin d'année on imagine le choc entre
hull français ultra classique et fleurie
de marivaux et le langage courant de ces
jeunes christophe airaud berlin puisse
jeans et baskets à peine 15 ans mais
déjà comédiens ans mme anne sara sabrina
et nanou vont nous raconter une histoire
d'ado dans des cages d'escaliers et ce
sont des mots théâtre qu'il se murmure
je voudrais bien voir baisser petit hall
elle éclaire sur moi vous serez sur
votre bouche à réclamer bah c'est pareil
quoi c'est pareil sera pareil j'ai
toujours droit dans l'east et avec du
mauvais y a que de la racaille des gens
qui sont pas civilisés isolé c'est pas
du tout ça quoi
on est capable tout autant de tout
autant que tout le monde toute autre
personne de réussir et de venir cueillir
d'habiter là où on est quoi les gameurs
était en bas d'immeuble les jeux de
l'amour et du hasard leur théâtre
devient un rap de marivaudage et de
prise de tête les mots ce que le but
dans ce conte des premiers émois
amoureux des lettres autre manière voilà
saint trond est venu chez nous a sorti
ça c'est quoi franchement à suivre à ça
fait trop ou alors ça fait trop je
trouve ça mais c'est vague comment sais
tu vas tu me casses les couilles il
prend quoi là
c'est une stigmatisation de des
banlieues alors que pour moi il s'agit
d'une jeunesse qui je trouve plutôt
surtout dans les émois amoureux fragile
belle tendre et bien ça va trop s'il
n'était pas d'être mystique ou quoi
franchement le seul truc qui m'a dit tu
as été mines une peur pas très élevé ce
qui voit la santé sont devant mais non
les indices mai
vous affirmez comme ça vous êtes comme
ça dans la vie
ba et ba ça c'est la plus grande
récompense ça veut dire que c'est elle
on a tellement travaillé que on s'est
libéré de de tout ce à quoi la ceinture
et le monde naturel à base de quelque
chose ça donne quelque chose de vous et
où l on peut être sûr que dans sa tombe
marivaux adore leskiw ses jeux de mots
entre maîtres et valets devienne une
douce subversion et son théâtre casse
l'image des banlieues incendiaires pour
devenir un terrain de jeu de comédiens
montre